MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Hello!
Are you enjoying Google I/O?
Whoa, that's great!
Let's hear it again,
because I'm going
to involve you in this session.
Are you enjoying Google I/O?
Fantastic.
I'm enjoying Google I/O a lot.
This morning, when I woke
up it felt like Christmas.
But then I thought, I'm
going to work today,
so it's not really Christmas.
But I don't work Christmas.
And then I thought I wonder what
Santa Claus' staff is feeling
on Christmas when
they are working?
That was a really weird
thought, so I stopped that.
We're going to talk today
about Google Play services.
And probably many of you in here
know what Google Play services
is, but I will do a
mandatory recap for you.
Because there may be
some people in here
that don't know what
Google Play services is.
Google Play services is a set of
APIs that we develop in Google
and deploy on Android
devices running Gingerbread
or later that has
Google Play installed.
And that's a lot of
devices out there.
There's just a small
percentage or two or so
of devices that runs
Google Play that
is not included in this set.
So it's a vast majority of
the Google Play devices.
It's unfortunate that you can
terminate the presentation
with the clicker, right?
And the good thing with
Google Play services
is it that we release it
many times every year.
So there are multiple
releases being
pushed to all of these
devices per year.
Now, if you're still
thinking, so what's
the big deal about that, then I
will tell you it's a huge deal.
It has monumental value, right?
Because this allows
Google to get the,
latest and coolest,
and most shiny
stuff that we develop
in mobile technology,
to get that out to
developers quickly.
Are you developers?
Yeah!
That's great.
And that stuff that you
develop on Google Play services
API can be used on almost
all the Google Play devices
out there.
That's great, isn't it?
If we look historically, we've
been releasing 12 Google Play
services versions since
we started with this back
in September 2012.
And I'm happy to announce
that right as we speak here,
we have 5.0 being
pushed out to the world,
and you will actually get a
sneak preview of this version
as well.
So more information on
that is coming later.
But it's going to
be great stuff.
Some of that stuff I
will present here today,
so stay tuned.
I love Google Play
services because of this.
Because it has all of
these capabilities that you
can build into
applications, right?
You have location with GPS.
You've got the maps,
the Wallet API.
You've got play game
services, mobile
adds, social with
Google Plus, ChromeCast
the Google Cast SDK,
Drive, and Cloud.
It's absolutely amazing.
You can build so many
cool applications
with all of these APIs.
COMPUTER: Tell them that
Google Play services rocks.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Yes,
that's exactly what I'm
going to tell you now.
Google Play services rocks.
It really, really rocks, right?
And we're going to do
a little exercise here.
I brought the t-shirt
launcher with me.
It looks like this, right?
And this is probably
what's going to happen.
At various locations
of this presentation,
I will go crazy, and
put my arms in the air.
And I will say Google
Play services--
and then I expect from you--
AUDIENCE: Rocks.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Yeah, exactly!
Exactly.
Let's try that out once.
So, OK, Google Play services--
AUDIENCE: Rocks!
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Whoa!
Great stuff.
A little reloading there.
I can just see this later.
Weird guy at Google I/O
launches t-shirts at audience.
Asks for rocks in return.
All right, let's get
started, shall we?
Ladies and gentlemen,
let's introduce a new API
to Google Play services, namely
the Android Wear Data API.
With a round of applause.
Here we go.
You've seen Android
Wearables being
launched at the keynote today.
And this is big stuff, right?
It's the first time
I'm wearing something
around my wrist for
the past 15 years.
I've been taking my phone
up and down this pocket.
I think in the
keynote today there
was a note that 100
billion times this
happens every day in the world.
It's amazing, isn't it?
I have tear marks
on my left pocket
here, because I'm reaching
for the phone so often.
Well those tear
marks I will not need
to have anymore, because I got
all of that information right
here on my wrist.
It's absolutely amazing.
And Google Play
services obviously
has an API to integrate
with these variable devices.
Because you need to transfer
things between these devices
and communicate across them.
And there are three APIs
that we are launching
as part of Google Play services
in the Android Wear data API.
The first part is
the message API.
The message API allows you to
send uni-directional messages
between the wearable and
the phone, or tablet.
Or the phone tablet
to the wearable.
These can be control signals.
For example, you can
tell the wearable
to change the media track that
is playing on your Android
phone.
Or you can have your Android
phone instruct the wearable
to launch an intent that
gets visible to the user.
So that's a great API
to share information
between the device you
have in the pocket,
and the wearable device.
The second API is the asset API.
The asset API is
used to transfer
binary blobs--
images, for example,
or other kinds of binary
data-- between the wearable
and the other device.
So this can, for
example, be an image.
One use case would be
your phone downloads
an image to the phone, right?
It resizes it to
match the resolution
of the wearable device.
And it then sends it over to
the wearable device as an asset.
That's a perfect example of data
being transferred as an asset.
Then we have DataItem.
DataItem is a message
exchange in this API
that allows you
to have data which
is in sync on both
the wearable device
as well as the other
device, such as the phone.
That means if it
changes on one side,
it would be automatically
synced on the other side.
So that's also a great API.
So this is really
fabulous, right?
What applications will we see
here in a couple of weeks?
I'm really, really
excited about this.
And as I said, the 5.0 release
of Google Play services,
we're giving you a
sneak preview of that.
So you'll have a
running or flying
start when you start
to check this out.
It's really, really great stuff.
So I think that
this demonstrates
that Google Play services--
AUDIENCE: Rocks!
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Yes!
Ooh.
It rocks, right?
It rocks.
Oh.
Wow.
OK, let's move on.
For wearables, we have a number
of different I/O sessions
here, right?
So this is a list of them.
You should definitely
go and check them out.
There are so many
resources that you
can consult during
these two days regarding
wearable technology.
Let's talk about the
buying experience, right?
I love to buy things.
Buying on mobile is not
very simple, or hasn't been,
at least.
Got three components that
makes it quite complex.
The identity component,
the payment component,
and the data entry.
Now, we worked on the
identity and payment
for a long time with
Google Plus, right?
And Wallet has been
around for a while, too.
So you have Google
Wallet to pay for things.
But the problem has been
also the data entry.
I mean, when you're
a mobile device,
it kind of looks
like this, right?
Big fingers on small keys.
How am I supposed to enter
my address using these keys?
That's impossible, right?
I can barely remember
my address, right?
Let alone enter it on
these types of keys.
I've seen people do it.
I mean, you've seen
teenagers they're like--
[FRANTIC GESTURE].
Two hands.
Multiple things being
used simultaneously.
Both hands, right?
Completely impossible.
I can't do it.
Lately, I have started to using
this kind of swiping moment,
you know?
Where you can swipe
the characters and they
form a word.
It's really cool.
I feel cool when I do it, also.
I will be home at 6:00 PM.
It's really, really cool.
I love it.
Well, the problem
is that it's not
easy to enter an address with
this kind of method either.
So we're happy that
we've released an address
API recently in
Google Play services.
Ladies and gentlemen,
you can now
sit in the comfort of
your best keyboard,
enter as many addresses
as you want, right?
And they get recorded
with the address API.
And applications can
they say, where do you
want to ship this thing?
It can then ask the address API.
The address API will ask
you to give permission
to the application
to have the address.
And voila!
The application will
get the address.
Not a single press
on any key, right?
It's just a user interface
to select which entry of that
list that you want to have.
Isn't that great?
I think this is fantastic.
This is a perfect
feature for me.
Another feature that
we're adding in 5.0
is the OCR scanning
of credit cards.
So as you can see here, you can
now press on the camera button
when you want your
credit card to scan,
you can just align your
card with this frame here.
And the card number will
be automatically provided
to this registration
of the new card.
That's also cool, right?
Because how many remember
their credit card numbers?
You're sitting there like, ugh.
Doesn't work.
So that's a great
addition, as well.
Wallet fragments.
It is now super easy to add
the Buy with Google button
to your application.
We reduced this to be a very,
very small, a minimum amount
of code that you need to use in
order to add this kind of stuff
to your application.
So we hope to see lots more
developers to embrace this
as well.
And we did a little
demo here that I
prerecorded for safety reasons.
And what we're going to see
here is me going into a site.
I have never been
to this site before.
Me going into this site
for the first time,
registering, logging
on to the site,
buying a bike, getting it
shipped, to my home address,
and all of that will happen
in less than 10 seconds.
So here we go.
So I log in with the
sign-in by Google button.
I select my account
that I want to use.
I come in, I select
the adjustable bike
that I want to buy
because it's cool.
I'm buying it with Google,
I confirmed the order
and the shipping address.
Voila!
10 seconds, and we've
just bought the bike.
Isn't that amazing?
Yeah.
I think that's great.
All right.
We're at that point, my gosh.
Because we need to do this.
I think that demonstrates
that Google Play services--
AUDIENCE: Rocks!
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Yes.
Whoa!
Do you want to have another one?
Yeah, I've got plenty of these.
Over there.
Whoa.
Great.
Let's move over to the
selling experience, right?
Because you can't have a buyer
unless you have a seller,
right?
So they're kind of
mutual dependent.
Even though it doesn't sound
as good to be selling things
for some reason, I don't know.
This is a picture of my wallet.
This is a very
important topic for me.
I want to try to keep my wallet
as small as I possibly can.
I'm down to below an
inch, something like that.
If I was to accept every single
loyalty program, or coupon,
or whatever I am offered
in my stores that I visit,
this wallet would probably
be 10 inches thick, right?
It would be like that.
If I was to sit down
with that kind of wallet,
I would kind of be tilting
to the side, right?
Because I would have this
wallet built up on one side.
I would have to do
a customized pocket
to be able to get that
wallet into my pants.
Well that, ladies and gentlemen,
is not needed anymore.
Because now we're
introducing to Wallet
the Save to Google button.
So let's welcome the
Save to Google button
with a round of applause.
That's right, let's
get back to work.
The Save Card to
Google allows you
to store loyalty cards--
but not only loyalty cards,
also coupons and
discounts and bonuses
and all other kinds
of stuff-- allows
you to store that
stuff in Google Wallet.
And then through applications
that you can create,
you can add this button
to your application,
so merchants that
you're interacting with
can store their stuff
to Google Wallet.
That's great, right?
It requires no more physical
space, all of these things.
And if we tie that together
with context and location.
For example, if I'm
walking into a store,
then that store can offer me
things based on what my loyalty
program is, my status is.
And also, it can utilize the
coupons that I've collected.
Because how many
are carrying around
all the different
coupons that you
are being offered in stores.
It doesn't happen.
This needs to happen if we're
going to have a pleasant buying
experience in the future.
Not to mention the
selling experience, right?
And this was actually one
of our partners, Belly,
that did an early
integration of this.
So we're very happy for that.
This functionality will keep
the merchants happy, of course.
They can offer the things.
They don't have to stand
there with a customer that
refuses to take a
card because they
don't have space in the wallet.
It will keep the
customers happy,
because they will get better
offers and better rewards.
And it will keep you
developers happy,
because you're connecting
the dots between the selling
endpoint and the buying endpoint
in this particular case.
It's a win-win-win.
It's the best value proposition
that you can create.
Perfect alignment between
all the parties, right?
It's amazing.
Another piece that we've had
added to Google Play service
system to make the
selling experience better
is Google Analytics.
Now, this was added
in March, 2014,
but it existed as a standalone
library before that.
Google Analytics
allows you to measure--
this is going to sound
terrible, but this is actually
true I think--
allows you to measure
what is most important to you.
And what does that mean?
It means that you can put
things in your application that
will get reported as
statistical information.
And later on, you can see how
your application behaves--
how your users are
interacting with it;
how they are discovering it,
downloading it, installing it;
when, under which conditions
they're upgrading to a paid
version, as opposed
to a free one;
when they're doing in-app
purchase, et cetera.
There's tons of material
here in Google Analytics
that you can use in order to
improve your app experience.
And that's pretty
good, because it
will make your
users happy, right?
You will provide an application
that makes sense to them.
And it can be good
for you, because you
can drive more revenue
through your app, as well.
So that's great stuff.
Google Analytics.
As part of 5.0, we've
added enhanced ecommerce
to Google Analytics.
And this provides even more
detailed level of reporting.
So now you can dice
and slice your data
that you get, all the way
down to the product level.
So you can see during the
purchasing process when
a user is going through
adding the card, et cetera,
and checking out.
You can see what they're
doing with that product
before they're
deciding to buy it.
For example, how
many users wants
to do the detailed product
page before they're
buying the product?
Is that relevant
for my product to be
sold, that there is a
product detail page or not?
So lots of stuff that
can be done here.
And ecommerce, as
you know, is an area
that's exploding
in terms of growth.
Tremendous amount of growth.
So this is a great addition
to Google Analytics.
Let's move over to mobile ads.
What we did previously
in Google Play services,
just recently, was we
added in-app purchase ads.
This allows users
to, in the device,
directly purchase virtual
goods that are advertised.
And it also allows the ads to
be targeted to different user
segments.
So depending on who you are,
you may get different ads.
And in 5.0, we also
made this extremely
easy by providing
APIs that allows
you to configure
this in a good way.
That's great stuff.
Don't you think that
this demonstrates
that Google Play services--
AUDIENCE: Rocks!
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Yes.
I hope it works.
Whoa!
Sorry.
That's better.
All right.
There is an I/O
session on Wallet
as well that you
should check out.
The Instant Buy Everywhere
is taking place.
Really great stuff on Waller.
Play Game Services.
Who likes to play games?
One or two.
I love games, right?
Especially I like zombie
games, for some reason
I haven't figured out.
OK, in games we've done a lot
of different stuff, right?
We've added
multiplayer recently.
Achievements is
now part of games.
And leaderboards.
You can see, if you see the
evolution of requirements,
things that we've
added to games,
that we're really creating a
great platform to build games
upon.
All the things that
you want to have,
that you had to build
yourself before is pretty much
becoming part of this platform.
And one thing we
have just recently
is Game Gifts API, which allows
a user to request a gift.
A wish.
To send a wish request.
To request a gift, right?
So this could be a
virtual life or something,
where you run out of life.
And another player can
send a gift request
to give something
to the other player.
And that, of course, will make
the first player very, very
happy.
Now happy players are
great, and if they're
collaborating to become
happy, that's even better.
Because that increases
the social engagement
between the players in games.
Pretty perfect, I think.
In 5.0, if we look
at 5.0 specifically,
we added gamer profile.
There's now a
centralized profile
for all your gaming activity.
Isn't that fantastic, right?
Yeah?
Is that fantastic or not?
Yeah, that's great.
So you have a
Living Game Profile,
and there you can store
experience points,
progresses in games,
leaderboard, achievements,
titles, and levels.
All of that stuff.
So that's good.
We also added saved games.
This allows you to
persist game progress.
If you want to pause
the game, for example.
And you can also add an image
to where the game was paused.
And you can resume
playing that game
from that position on any
other device that you have.
So that's pretty
great stuff as well.
A big enhancement in Play
games services for 5.0
is the introduction
of events and quests.
So what are these things?
Let's start with events.
Events are lightweight
counters in your game.
So it could be, for example,
a player has opened a treasury
chest in the magical room of
floor two in the weird castle.
Stuff like that.
And this allows you to
look at these events
and how users are
interacting with your game.
So you can see which parts of
your games are used frequently
and which parts are
not used so frequently.
And that brings
us over to quests.
Because these
events, you can then
create quests based on those.
So one example would be kill
5,000 zombies using a spoon
before Sunday 8:00 PM.
Hey guys, we got to
cancel that hiking trip.
Yeah, it's the zombies again.
No, it's with a spoon this time.
OK, great, right?
So that's perfect.
You can now have quests
built right in there for you,
and available.
And I think that
that demonstrates
that Google Play services--
AUDIENCE: Rocks!
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Whoa!
One more.
Usually when I squeeze to me
like that they go really far.
There we go.
That was a good shot.
All right.
There are I/O sessions,
multiple I/O sessions
on Play Games services.
You should definitely
check them out.
I don't think that mobile
gaming will reduce,
it will rather increase in
terms of usage over the years.
So there will be a lot of
stuff that we can do in this.
Activity recognition.
This is one of my favorite areas
because we're getting physical
here.
Previously, in
activity recognition,
you could detect the following
different activities--
if you were on a bike, if
you're on a vehicle, if you were
still, or tilting, or on foot.
But we decided that
that was not enough.
So we added--
COMPUTER: Walking and running.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: That's right.
We added walking and
running to activities.
And now, we would have
a live demonstration
from Adam Metcalf,
my colleague who
is working as a software
engineer in the core Google
Play services team.
ADAM METCALF: Hi,
I'm Adam Metcalf.
I'm a software engineer on
the Google Play services team.
I thought I'd come up here and
share a demo with you that I
wrote that will be included in
the samples section of Google
Play services SDK.
The demo is essentially
activity recognition, including
Play Games for a leaderboard and
dumping some files onto Drive
later so you can
recap how it went.
I will start it now.
COMPUTER: Game
started, get ready.
ADAM METCALF: It
gives you enough time
to put in your
pocket, because we're
going to do activity
recognition.
COMPUTER: Stop.
ADAM METCALF: So stop
meaning be really still.
COMPUTER: You're doing it.
ADAM METCALF: Yay.
This game is very much like
red light, green light.
COMPUTER: Start walking.
ADAM METCALF: So it told
me to start walking,
so I'll start walking.
And takes about 10 seconds or
so for the activity recognition
to kick in because it wants to
be very sure that you're not
just shaking the phone.
Walking on a stage is not
the greatest place for this.
COMPUTER: Keep it up.
ADAM METCALF: Yay.
There we go.
COMPUTER: Stop.
Almost.
ADAM METCALF: Aw.
I was moving too much.
I'm shaking up here.
COMPUTER: Yes.
All right.
Start walking.
ADAM METCALF: OK, let's
do this a little bit more.
COMPUTER: You're doing it.
ADAM METCALF: All right.
COMPUTER: Yes.
All right.
Start running.
ADAM METCALF: OK, let's see
how this works on stage.
COMPUTER: Almost.
Oh no.
ADAM METCALF: Aw, c'mon.
COMPUTER: Keep trying.
ADAM METCALF: I can do it.
Stop.
ADAM METCALF: And that's
going to conclude the game.
COMPUTER: Keep it up.
Game over.
Your score was 775.
ADAM METCALF: All right.
So we get that up on the
screen, when it comes up.
So when the game
concludes, it'll
submit a score to the Google
Play Games leaderboard.
And because the Wi-Fi in this
place is not the greatest,
it'll do it offline and
eventually send it up
when I next get connected.
You can see that it
has a tracking of when
I hit all the
activity recognitions.
And you can even
open up a leaderboard
and see how I'm doing.
I did not beat my high score,
so I'll have to keep trying.
All right.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Round
of applause for Adam.
So that was an example of a
game that used the location API,
that used the leaderboards
in Play Games services,
and it used the Drive
API to store a file
with the progress of the game.
We have this slide, as well.
This shows you how these
different clients within Google
Play services was connected
to the Google API client.
Something you've probably seen.
It's a new connectivity
methodology
in the core parts of
Google Play services.
It makes these
things, connecting
different clients,
really, really easy.
So it's a very,
very good feature.
So now we have
walking and running.
That's exciting, right?
We have a lot of stuff here now.
It feels like you
can build a lot
of physical,
interactive games if you
combine all of these APIs.
I'd like to see more of that
coming out to Google Play.
And I think this demonstrates
that Google Play services--
AUDIENCE: Rocks!
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: That's right!
OK, there we go.
All right, let's move
over to Google Cast SDK.
The Google Cast SDK was
released in February 2014.
This is amazing, right?
Suddenly your mobile
device, your Android device,
becomes a remote control for any
Chromecast-enabled TV screen.
It's quite amazing,
I think, what
you can do with it from an
application perspective.
Together with that API,
there's another API
you can use which is a Cast
Companion Library, which
makes certain operations in the
Google Cast SDK easier to do.
So that's something
to keep in mind.
There's also an I/O session
on Google Cast, or ChromeCast,
Casting to the Future,
that you should take up
if you're interested in
looking more into Chromecast.
Now, Google Drive Android API
was released in January 2014.
This is a native
API that allows you
to interact with Drive
content of any user that
has given their consent,
of course, for this.
So this is a great
way, also, to access
the hard drives for
different users.
And this is a feature which
is due in 5.0, which is great,
I think.
It's the App Indexing API.
This API allows you, through
Google Play services,
to report things in your
app, deep within your app,
content deep within your
app that gets picked up
and becomes available
to Google Search.
And obviously, that can
drive more user interaction
with your app because you can
actually now expose the stuff
that you do deep within your
app to the general internet.
So it drives user engagement.
Great feature as well.
Google Fit.
You should definitely
go up to level three
to check out the
Google Fit station.
This station will show you how
to manage your fitness data.
That's a perfect place.
And then dynamic
security providers,
an area that I'd like
to touch upon, as well.
Dynamic Security provider is a
feature in Google Play services
that will allow you to pick
up a security provider.
Now, if vulnerabilities
is detected, for example,
in SSL protocol, or whatever,
these vulnerabilities
will be fixed as part of the
push of Google Play services.
That means that your apps
that you're developing
do not need to embed
this kind of logic,
and they don't need
to be updated to cater
for these different problems.
All the security
things are being
dealt with with the
Google Play services push.
All right.
Moving to the Google
Maps Android API.
The Google Maps
Android API has been
part of Google Play services
for a long time now,
since Android version 2.0.
The version 2.0 has been
part of Google Play services
since December 2012.
But just recently, we're
happy to introduce, yes,
this is a major
feature, I think.
It is the Street View
capability of Google Maps.
Let's introduce it with a
round of applause, please.
Get back to work, yeah.
All right.
This capability will
allow your users
to explore the world using
panoramic 360 degrees
views, right?
And they can work with
the Street View camera
to zoom in and also control
the camera location.
And, of course, all the
movements that you do
will be animated.
These are now
capabilities that you
can get natively into your app.
So it's a major extension.
It's absolutely amazing.
If you look at some of the
things we just added to this,
it's the Tubbataha coral
reefs in Philippines.
You can actually swim
around in this reef,
and check it out,
using Street View.
And another one, that
you may have seen before,
is that you can actually
explore different base
camps of Mount Everest.
There's tremendous
stuff in Street View
that you can explore using
this type of feature.
And I thought, now when
we have Street View,
it's actually possible to
create a dual time space, right?
So given that we
have location, where
I can register my
current location,
right, I can have Street View
display my current location.
So I could be walking
down the street, right?
I challenge for somebody
to develop this app.
I could be walking
down the street,
experiencing the real
world with my body,
but have the world that was
recorded when the Street View
camera passed by.
I can get that experience
at the same time.
So kind of two time
dimensions at the same time.
And if somebody would
come up to me to say,
you're crazy, what
are you doing?
COMPUTER: Magnus is not here.
He is traveling in time.
Can I leave a message?
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Then I
could have that triggered.
Absolutely amazing.
We can build a time machine,
a kind of a time machine,
by using these capabilities.
And I think that
this demonstrates
that Google Play services--
AUDIENCE: Rocks!
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Are you OK?
That's great.
There are also a
couple of sessions
on Maps during this I/O,
so go and check them out.
There is also a Dev
I/O Byte available
that you can check
out on the internet.
Great, so Google Play
services rocks, right?
You can get the latest stuff we
develop here at Google, latest
and most shiny stuff that we
develop in mobile technology.
And that can be
available to all of you
mobile developers out
there in the world,
to create great apps that
are available in almost all
of the Google Play
devices out there.
It's quite amazing.
So we have social, we have
activity, we have games,
we have commerce,
Cast, Location, Drive,
Cloud, and Maps.
I'm happy I caught my
breath between those,
otherwise I wouldn't have
been able to read that out
in a single sentence.
It is a fantastic
framework for you
to go out and create
fantastic apps.
In fact, it's your
turn to go out
there and create great apps.
And don't forget to
tell us all about it.
Thank you so much for
having us in this session.
It was great talking to you.
Adam, come up.
So we have time for a couple
of questions, I think.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So I was curious
about-- it's great
that services are
pulled out, and you
get the advantage of them
being updated automatically
without the user having
to update your app.
But in general, like with the
Nokia X or the Amazon Fire,
you can't get some
of these services
without the Play Store.
So are you guys
thinking about offering
an alternative, either a library
or some other way of getting
at these services
without the Play Store?
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: No.
They're tightly
integrated, the Google
Play Store and
Google Play services.
It forms the same concept.
In fact, Google Play
services is an APK
within the Play Store itself.
AUDIENCE: But certain things
like GCM, or Ads, or even
Analytics, I wouldn't
say necessarily--
like Wallet absolutely should
be part of the Play Services.
But there are certain
services that you
can make a case that would
be beneficial to both Google
and the developers that
wouldn't be tightly integrated
in Play services.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: OK, all right.
Now, I think that
the strategy is
to have them together, bundled.
OK, next question,
over to the left.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I would like to know if the
credit card scan feature,
it's available without
using Google Wallet.
For example, with
another payment method.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: The what?
Which feature?
AUDIENCE: Credit card scan.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN:
As far as I know,
that is an integral
part of Google Wallet.
So it works together with
the Google Wallet account.
AUDIENCE: OK, thank you.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Thank you.
Next question.
AUDIENCE: So it's awesome to
see that Google Play services is
constantly evolving.
But some key APIs have
been deprecated or removed,
I think, recently, like
Wallet Client and Plus Client.
And it's not really always clear
on the Google Play services
page, what's deprecated
and what's not,
unless I go to the
individual pages.
So what's the best way
for me as a developer
to plan ahead for these,
so I can make time
to make these changes.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN:
That's a good question.
You'll find out when
you get the next SDK
and just get the warning
messages in the compiler,
I guess.
It's a good question.
I don't have a good answer.
But we have been
looking at trying
to get more information
out preemptively about what
has changed API-wise, also.
Not only on the high level, new
APIs that are being launched.
So I'll take that as
something to think about.
Next question.
AUDIENCE: As Google
Play services continues
to get larger and
larger, are you
thinking about breaking it
up into modules optionally?
So developers don't have
to include such a giant JAR
in their project files.
ADAM METCALF: We've
been looking into it.
Nothing to confirm or deny yet.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: All
right, next question.
AUDIENCE: I actually
have the same question,
although-- I've heard a
lot of developers running
into this issue, especially
with actually running to the DEX
limit with more recent
versions of Play services.
So it's becoming more
and more of a pain point.
Since you answered
his question, I
have another question,
which is what is tilting?
ADAM METCALF: I think
it's when there's
been a significant motion.
Not significant motion, but
it's like the user has picked up
the device, and there's
been some amount
of tilting to let you know that
it was sitting down on a table
or something, and
you've picked it up.
AUDIENCE: So it's not
like some weird phenomenon
people are doing?
ADAM METCALF: No,
it's not like tilting.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: All
right, next question.
AUDIENCE: I'm working on an
app that saves information
as files in a file system.
I would like to be able
to synchronize that
across several devices, so I
was looking at the Dropbox API.
It looks like Google Drive
might serve my purposes.
So would it serve my purposes?
Would it be able to
present the information
as if it were a file system?
One of the problems
with the Dropbox
is it requires the inclusion
of a lot of shared libraries.
So I need to include
a large shared
library for every
different processor.
And there's no shared
libraries or anything.
This is just a web service.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: So the
Drive API is a native API.
It's statically compiled
to get rid of the binary.
So there's not a
web services API.
And it allows you to do offline
syncing with the device,
as well.
And you can create
offline folders and stuff.
So it's a perfect
API to access files
such as in a hard drive
with different users.
It sounds like it's something
you should check out.
AUDIENCE: Sounds like from
the last two questions
I might have the
same space problem.
Because one of the problems
I had with the Dropbox is it
required these two
large shared libraries.
OK.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Thank you.
Two more questions, I think.
Do we have time?
Are we OK with time?
One question, one minute?
One more question.
AUDIENCE: This one shouldn't
count towards your limit.
Will you shoot me
with your t-shirt gun?
ADAM METCALF: You
don't want that.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: You
want me to shoot it?
AUDIENCE: Have you ever
shot anybody with it?
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: No, no, no.
Well, no, I haven't.
But here, I'll shoot
it one final time.
Are you ready?
OK.
Ooh, that's really far,
it's way back there.
That was a good final shot.
Thank you so much for
coming to this session.